So that's pretty cool.
So we have an upper bound, that says
that our algorithm is not going to take
any longer than n squared k steps
to explore a deterministic MBP.
And a reasonable question to ask is,
is that good or bad?
And so what I want to argue next
is that there's a lower bound,
saying that no algorithm can do
better than n squared k, and
therefore algorithms
actually doing very well.
>> No.
Well, as well as one can do.
>> As well as one can do, right.
Which may help you well enough.
Now when in fact, really when you're
trying to learn in this kinds of
domains, you don't really want to
make worst case assumptions.
So this is under a worst
case assumptions,
where there's really no
structure in the MBP.
How many mistakes might we make en
route to finding the optimal policy.
>> Okay.
>> All right, so
let me draw a little MBP.
So here's an MBP that we can
call a combination lock.
So the basic idea of this is that we've
got some kind of n state sequence and
two actions,
which I drew as purple and blue here.
And each state has a purple action and
a blue action.
And one of them goes
back to this reset state,
this state number one, while the other
one advances up the chain one step.
>> I see.
>> And so
we need to explore this whole thing say,
because there's some kind of giant
reward over here, and every step that
we're not making along this chain and
then looping around here is a mistake.
So the question is,
how many mistakes might we make en
route to finding this plus 100?
So let's say we start off
in this state number one.
So what would our max do in this case,
Charles?
>> It would pick one of them,
because they look the same.
>> Right, so it's in this state,
it doesn't know anything
about the outgoing actions.
And it knows that there is purple and
blue, and it picks one.
And I tried to be kind of random about
the way which one would go forward and
which one would go backwards so
there's really nothing you
can do other than guess.
If you guess wrong,
then you take this blue action and
end up back in state one.
At which point you would say,
I know what that does,
let me try the purple action.
And now it advances
us to the next state.
>> Right.
>> All right, so what happens from here?
>> Well, you don't know what time
it's going to happen next so
you pick one of them.
>> Right.
So if we choose the purple one we get
reset back to the beginning, at which
point we can kind of march up the chain,
and, you know, get back to where we
have some unknown information and
then try blue.
But basically each time we're exploring
one of these states it's taking us,
well, if you think of it as state i.
To explore state i we take one action,
which resets us back to the beginning
and it takes us i steps
to get back to i.
And then one more to get
to the new state i +1.
So the total number of steps
that we're taking here is
going to be 1 + 2 + 3 + 4,
all the way up to n.
>> Right,
that looks very n squared to me.
>> Which is exactly right,
which is n squarish, as some people say.
And so this total number of steps we
take, it's not literally n squared, but
it's some constant times n squared.
And you can't really
do better than that.
Now in this particular case, we really
wanted to prove a lower bound that was
going to relate it to k times n squared,
where k is the number of actions,
here the number of actions was two.
Do you think the same example
actually kind of scales up for
greater and greater k?
How would you change this example so
that it would basically force us
to do k actions times n squared.
>> Well, I can just make all but
one of them send you back.
>> Yeah, okay, so
let's think about what that would do.
So if we had k actions, one of them sent
us forward and we have no idea which one
and all the other ones send
us back to the beginning.
Then what's going to happen is we're
going to have each time we explore state
i, we're actually going to get reset and
have to take n steps k times.
>> Right.
>> So for each of the n states,
essentially, we're going to have to
explore all the actions and for all but
one of them it's going to be n
steps to get back to where we
are exploring again.
And look at that!
>> That looks like n squared k.
Or Kn squared.
>> Yeah, I just reordered it so that it
looked more like the thing on the top.
>> If you remember from our
last machine learning class,
everything got us back to k and n.
And there you go.
>> Oh!
Nice.
>> It's all the same.
>> It's always k's nearest neighbors,
but in this case, it's not.
>> It's k's farthest neighbors.
>> Well, yeah,
I guess there's some truth in that.
That each time we take an action that we
don't know about, we're getting unlucky,
and we're having to take a very long
trail to get back to where we started.
But no,
I'm just saying k nearest Neighbors
is a particular kind of algorithm.
And here, n doesn't stand for
neighbor here, right?
It stands for number of states.
>> I prefer to think that n stands for
neighbor in this case.
>> Great, okay, then I think
we've got this one under control.
So that's the argument that I
wanted to make there is that
we really do have to take kn squared in
the worst case in a deterministic NBP,
to figure out what's going on and
stop making mistakes.
>> Yeah, and there's no error on it,
because this is like, well,
it really is a combination lock.
The way you draw it it's a random
binary string that gets you to the end.
Unless you get extremely lucky,
there's no way to figure out
what it is without trying all
the combinations, sort of.
>> Well, it's not all the combinations.
So combination lock in some ways
is actually not a great name here,
so in particular, what makes it
a combination lock is to make it
across this whole chain of end things.
You have to choose the right color and
sequence.
You have to choose, in this case,
purple, blue, purple, purple, blue,
blue, blue, blue, blue.
So you have to kind of crack the lock.
>> Right.
>> In a real combination lock,
if you get any of these wrong,
at the end of it,
you don't get to find out which ones
were right and which ones were wrong.
You get reset back to the beginning and
you just have to start again.
So you really end up taking like number
of actions to the number of states.
>> Right.
>> Different combinations.
Here we're lucky enough to
actually know, hey, the first
i parts of our combination are correct,
and we're just guessing the ith one.
>> So really,
it's a sequential combination lock.
>> Yeah, which is not very secure from
a, I don't know, security standpoint.
>> Well, in particular you can
solve it in n squared time
instead of k to the n time.
>> Right, so n squared doesn't sound so
bad if you're comparing
it to k to the n.
>> Right.
>> But anyway,
[LAUGH] the point is that
we can't get around that.
And so
that's really what I wanted you to do.
So the next thing I want to talk about
is combining this idea with the bandit
idea that we talked about earlier,
and get an algorithm for general MDPs.
>> Okay.